welcome to this video playing the
marzipan Kent marzipan is this really an
English word as well it's something in
German from Australia got a ton of games
but didn't play them often
let's see I'm going to do something else
deferred Steinitz that's very a bit yeah
this is what often happens if you play a
slightly over beat line people don't
really know what's going on um yeah
how is this played really G 697 it's
also possible
g 6 sort of reinventing everything here
I don't know it but I think this should
be possible yeah I have this counter
play against t4 in case of him taking
hmm you know it feels like he knows what
he's doing do you play that that looks
ugly it looks really ugly but Bishop e7
looks really wrong I have six also okay
that happens if you play stuff on an
experimental basis M okay maybe I can
put it on f7 m2 later block the Bishop
from b3 maybe intending no idea for but
this looks uglier I admit it
not something that I would like to
repeat in exactly the same fashion
interesting deployment of this night
night on a three
my D to look term far more ya far more
natural um okay what am i doing next am
I going to play f5 yeah I would like to
do that but this diagonal looks
problematic so I probably have to to do
something like that
okay Knight to c4 yeah this Knight
definitely put some pressure on e5 but I
still can do that yeah I have if I've
really really well protected maybe you
can take play Bishop c5 stuff like that
no it's taking them hmm how do I play it
if I take with the pawn this the pawn
takes pawn takes Bishop c5 looks rook e8
and then my man I don't have seven hangs
him with the knight move I wonder if I
should just take with the bishop and
reCAPTCHA on e5 with with pieces yeah
okay come on
this is this is also very fairly solid
fairly solid position I'm not really
sure about the other one does this look
this could be very shaky in the center
well this um this should be alright
yeah this is all right for like why does
at best slightly but I am Jack
now my king position is a bit shaky but
if I get in like Queen f6 and trade
trade pieces I cannot see it see six
yeah I cannot do without them I'm also
threatening if you want um Bishop e6
okay where does he want you go to b6
maybe I go rook e8 what is your move
Queen d4 check I go Queen f6 I mean this
is like totally okay jack after the
Queen trade I have no problems
whatsoever
okay we are Ruby 7 and OS that is
they're more powerful moves really
rookie 5 rocky sadness is perfectly okay
no need to second-guess IAM check
yeah well this is just equal what can
you do
takes Queenie five or something like
that
yeah then we have the typical Mouse race
again well what is twenty seconds uh
sure and feel it's a obliged to try to
do something okay so I'm putting
something on dark squares iam he's
putting his pawns on light squares which
is welcome but not mattering that much
I'm really a bit unsure what his idea is
here it's really miss placing his pawns
iam or some way for this it's really not
not advice but it is yeah mom he has
some leeway here of course it's very
hard to totally spoil this
there's some way forward here for me I
don't really think so brah our third
game yeah I mean he played it a bit
strangely with putting some stuff on
light squares but there is still
absolutely no way for our gym it's like
a fortress King on e3 and he just stays
like that and shuffles it's nothing that
I can do but it's it's difficult to to
avoid really a few if you go back here
here I mean it's not like my play was
unambitious or so but after taking I was
I was concerned that this is a problem
and yeah well the computer agrees
exactly the line that I was giving
during the game it's it puts pressure
here and I don't really have that great
a move
okay now the comp gives Knight age six
but this looks unnatural to me now
something that I don't really know don't
like that very much at least I was
preferring to play it simpler and well
this D takes d5 is of course leading to
a simplified position what what really
surprised me is that stockfish gives a
widely cleared share with rook e1 and
then Bishop d4 surprisingly huh maybe
maybe this is definitely better but is
it really a problem we had
okay born yeah this is definitely more
precise it puts this this on on to the
map and it's not so clear what I'm doing
now something like this is is very very
bad player prep move like that yeah
there are there are little problems yeah
but they they add up I mean here I
cannot play this and so on
check your interesting this is this is
probably quite good for wider this was
some change relatively is simply okay
shall we check this yeah no I mean I I
was thinking that he's maybe intending
to her to enter so I went for queenie
fire after which we have this really
draws endgame yeah sometimes it happens
okay thanks for watching